ensuite sur l'article du monde d'abord
ce n'est ni un interview est encore
moindre déclaration
vous l'avez compris nous sommes un
article journalistes m'appellent un
moment j'ai bataillé contre la fusion
des listes
toute la journée nous sommes au deuxième
jour pardon premiers jours après
l'élection
après premier tour se pose la question
des dépôts de listes
je suis intimement persuadé que le
deuxième tour ne peut pas se tenir
d'ailleurs j'arrête ma campagne et je
bataille parce que je ne suis pas
favorable à ce qu'on continue
les tractations politiques et je demande
qu'on arrête c'est à ce moment là que je
suis appelé ça n'est pas un interview
sinon j'aurais relu ses propos sévères
bâti ne m'ont jamais été soumis et
encore moins une déclaration
voilà donc on n'est pas là je pense pour
interpréter ses propos je suis là pour
rendre des comptes devant la
représentation nationale et j'espère
clarifier la façon dont j'ai géré cette
crise au moment où j'étais au ministère
est-ce que ensuite sur pied de nouveaux
permis avec l'industrie pharma qui
témoignent sur ce point mais ce que ces
propos sont vrais ou pas tenus ou non
ils sont des jeux sincèrement monsieur
le rapporteur
j'avais passé une journée pouvant table
j'étais très fatigué on m'accusait sur
les réseaux sociaux de n'avoir rien vu
et c'est tout le contraire je me suis
battu pendant un mois alors que je
défendrai la loi de bioéthique au sénat
cette semaine n'ont que j'avais la loi
sur les retraites que j'avais la grêle
des hôpitaux les collectifs interroge en
gros il ya tout ça c'est avec la réforme
des retraites
la loi de bioéthique au sénat jour et
nuit et la grève des hôpitaux
tout ça s'est fait sans que personne ne
voie rien quand j'étais au banc au sénat
j'étais en relation avec le premier
ministre ou avec le directeur général de
la santé pour gérer la crise donc que
j'ai dit au monde ce jour-là c'était
arrêter de dire que j'ai rien vu j'ai
tout vu j'ai tout vu j'ai préparé cet
article laisse penser que je n'ai pas
préparé
c'est pour ça que je voulais m'expliquer
devant la représentation nationale
parce que j'ai pressenti j'ai senti un
an j'ai bien avant les autres
le premier ministre l'a tout de suite
perçu avec moi et il a été avec moi en
permanence il m'a fait une confiance
totale
pendant cette période j'ai travaillé
main dans la main avec le gouvernement
avec le mae avec le premier ministre
avec le directeur général de la santé
pour gérer au mieux préparer au mieux ce
retour d'expérience permettra de voir ce
qu'on pense qu'on peut faire mieux mais
je répondais à ces réseaux sociaux un
article du parisien qui se moquaient de
moi en disant que je n'avais rien vu et
je pense que c'est un article du monde
ce rapporteur